Denzel studio called man I went to
equalizer to equalize it to good it's
will be better than equalizer 1aq 2aq -
you ain't I don't do sequels seriously
and it's not like movie star just fall
out of the sky is what you should do you
should audition
Liam be a stars see if any of them could
be wrong at all good ball NBA star I
like that watch the NBA Finals to see
who will be the next equalizer first
time no no no long time ago different
life now you come back yes I'm looking
for something you can find whatever you
wish important about a man who kidnapped
little girl from her American mother
would look be looking for such a time
will be there Jess for you men like him
with
[Music]
Robert I'm the only friend it's great
you helping all these random people and
everything but stay off the radar
something happened to one of ours
so I'm obligated to look into it thought
you retired oh I am just like you're
dead yeah what's the matter
[Music]
they knew the floor she was on we're
tying up loose ends
exactly partner for seven years let's
mistake to go to war with him with me
whoever did this of all chart skillsets
Everett the agency family gives East I
tried very good well not one one goat
they killed my friends
so I'm gonna kill each and every one of
them and then they disappoint me is that
I only get to do it once
[Music]
senior care and all those books around I
figured you for some kind of teacher
from a high level paid from the assassin
you